you cannot trust the things of this
world that always let you down
you cannot trust in yourself
because you're not perfect and you
always make mistakes
and you cannot trust in other people
because they always let you down
but if your confidence is in God you
will always have peace and joy
hey guys have you ever seen mature
Christian men and man it just looks like
nothing can get this guy down
you become like that how how does he do
it they just act in strength they always
walk talk and act in boldness and with a
lot of confidence
so how do they do it and where does this
confidence come from
well it is not self-confidence it is God
confidence
and today I want to talk to you about
this very important distinction
but I believe every Christian man should
know the difference between
self-confidence and God confidence
in your life it can be natural normal
for you to rely on your own human
abilities and strengths but that is also
where your power will end
and that's pretty sad but as reborn
Christians we are called to rely on
God's strength
his power and not our own we are called
to place our confidence in God and not
in ourselves
because there is where we will get more
power to be able to overcome things that
we will never be able to overcome with
just our own human power
our abilities come from him in the first
place but he can do a lot more than our
abilities he gives us equips us with
what we need to accomplish his will so
we don't just need to rely on ourselves
if you understand it and if you obey it
your whole life will change because you
understand that there is nothing in this
temporary world that can overcome you
why because the god of the Universe I
mean he spoke the whole universe into
existence
man
he is not limited by anything not by
time space matter or anything at all
God is in your corner and he will fight
with you not only with you but for you 1
John 4 verse 4 says Little Children You
are from God and have overcome them for
he who is in you is greater than he who
is in the world self-confidence is not
totally wrong if you understand it in
the correct way understanding who you
are who God made you to be being content
with your identity in Christ
then that is okay to understand it but
still as human beings Our Own Strength
is limited your human abilities are
limited and your confidence in yourself
can fall especially when faced with
challenges that are beyond your control
which usually happens in this world
but as reborn Christians
we are not alone so why do you keep on
living and fighting as if you are on
your own
as a reborn Christian
in your body which is the temple of God
you have received the spirit of God
Romans 8 verse 9 you however are not in
the flesh but in the spirit if in fact
the spirit of God dwells in you anyone
who does not have the spirit of Christ
does not belong to him
so when you stop looking at yourself all
the time trying to have self-confidence
placing your trust your confidence
relying on yourself and you take that
out and you place it in Christ it
changes everything for you
because now you tap into his Limitless
power
love peace all the spiritual blessings
we have already received in Christ
we only need to access it and then doing
it the right way through the part of the
Holy Spirit the holy spirit will now
help you and guide you your emotions
your intellect your own will to act
within the will of God
do you understand what I'm saying
the will of God will flow through you
towards the outside world
God's blessing will be upon you if
you're active in the will of God meaning
if you walked within the spirit you have
nothing to fear nothing at all the evil
in this world everything in this world
temporary that's temporary God has
already overcome this world
and you have overcome it through Christ
that is in you
so when you act within the power of God
through his Spirit everything will work
out the way it should
and he will help you in your weakness
even when you pray to God when there are
times when you're not sure exactly what
to pray he will help you
Romans 8 verse 26 likewise the spirit
helps us in our weakness for we do not
know what to pray for us we ought but
the spirit himself intercedes for us
with groanings too deep for words
we walk boldly in faith with power
trusting God in everything every aspect
of our lives so if you pray God what is
my purpose what do you want me to do
with my life
and if he talks to you through the realm
of work and he says that you have to
study theology to become a preacher then
you do it
trusting him knowing that he will give
you what you need to study Theology and
also after that you can pray and say all
right God now I've studied theology I'm
ready to become a preacher where do you
want me to go to what church how do you
want me to do this
he talks to you and then you act
according to what he says you need to do
if he says you need to go and marry Mary
Mary
then you do it if he says do this you do
it if he says do that you do it you walk
according to his will you trust that he
will help you will be there guiding you
but he will also give you equip you with
what you need to accomplish his will for
your life John 14 21 Whoever has my
Commandments and keeps them he it is who
loves me and he who loves me Will Be
Loved by my father and I will love him
and manifest myself to him
Jesus also said that man will not live
by bread alone but by every word of God
right but that word is not the logos
word that is the Rima that is what God
communicates to you you understand you
need to understand this so the logos the
word is is the word that God has already
revealed to us the Bible but then he
also speaks to us through the Rima
through the Holy Spirit
so in the Bible when you read it it
doesn't say go and marry marry or do
this or do that and call you by name but
that is what he does through the rimmer
word that's how he guides you in your
temporary life that you are living in
now specifically telling you to do
specific things and then you walk in
that room over
so you see God will not just help you
with the logos word but also the real
mower through the holy spirit that is in
you guiding you every step of the way in
your life every day if you trust him and
if you let him Lead You Now take this
verse write it on your heart and live it
Philippians 4 13 Amplified version
I can do all things which he has called
me to do through him who strengthens and
empowers me
to fulfill his purpose I am
self-sufficient in Christ's sufficiency
I'm ready for anything and equal to
anything through him who infuses me with
inner strength and confident peace
wow
man this is amazing
you know there are so many
self-improvement coaches in this world
and it works a little bit but it doesn't
really bring a lasting change
why not
because everyone realizes at some point
in their lives that they are only human
and that they cannot do everything by
themselves on their own that they cannot
control everything they get unexpectedly
ill they lose their job
someone close to them dies they do not
win the sports match they worked so hard
for
War breaks out in their country
covet hits and the list goes on in
moments like these lying to yourself and
telling yourself man I have confidence
and everything will work out the way it
should is it's kind of like hoping in
nothing because you have no power to
change reality
the reality that is outside of you there
are things in this world that you cannot
control
I have seen this so many times men who
try to act and think and try to force
themselves to actually believe
themselves their own lies but they are
more than they are and that by just
thinking positively it will somehow
change the reality and then when reality
hits them in the face they are shocked
and surprised and their whole world just
crumbles you see that especially with
young men
who have insecurities and they think
that the answer is trying to tell
themselves that they are alpha males and
they try to Puff themselves up like with
men in a boxing match they try to tell
themselves I will not lose I'm the best
I'm the strongest I'm great
I I
and then that eye gets knocked out
if not in that match in a later match
and also in life we are all mortal
for some reason a lot of us young guys
when I used to be young I used to think
like that
but over the years I saw
men die
strong men die right before my eyes
and the way they died
changed my perspective of Life they used
to feel powerful ruling their own small
world
only to come to this inevitable moment
to come to the end of their lives before
they die realizing they are weak just a
human
whose time has come and they are only
dust
you know this realization changed one of
these men that I knew
completely before he died he used to be
I mean he was bigger than me he used to
be very arrogant and uh man just living
for this world and puffed up and always
when he walked into a room you know he
would take control of the room and
trying to kind of force his his way
through life and
oh man he changed
I have never seen someone change that
drastically like this man when he come
to realize the truth of the world and
himself no one could tell this guy
anything at all he was always right me
I'm the man and now he comes to the end
of his life weak powerless
he couldn't even drive himself or even
go to the toilet by himself I had to
help him Psalm 8 verse 4 says what is
man that you are mindful of him and the
son of man that you care for him
having God's confidence changes
everything
it makes you realize who you truly are
your identity in him you start to see
the world differently you get different
perspectives helping you to overcome
challenges much faster
oh man
the person I used to be
if I know
man if I knew what I know now I would
have been so much different made so many
better decisions the more you grow in
God the more he changes you to become
stronger
in a sense you you get weaker in your
own fleshly sinful nature you get
stronger who the spirit in him and you
grow in that confidence
and you see how he is changing you he's
the Potter you are the plane you're
becoming stronger
meaning your confidence viewed in the
right way grows far beyond normal humans
who are spiritually dead
because their confidence isn't temporary
material things
while you are Anchored In God himself
you finally start to understand your
purpose you you understand your true
identity in him God says in Jeremiah 17
verse 5 cursed is the man who trusts in
man and makes flesh his strength
whose heart turns away from the Lord
here's like a shrub in the desert
and shall not see any good come
he shall dwell in the parched places of
the Wilderness in an uninhabited salt
land blessed is the man who trusts in
the Lord whose trust is the Lord
now listen carefully to this
he is like a tree planted by water that
sends out its roots by the stream and
does not fear when he comes for its
leaves remain green
and it is not anxious in the year of
drought for it does not cease to bear
fruit do you get it this world can do
what it wants to you but if your
confidence is in God you will always
have peace and joy it's like the tree
you know the rain can come the storms
can come the sun can beat in the day but
the roots are in the living water
your confidence your roots is in the
living water which is the holy spirit
God's spirit that is within you tapping
into that unlimited power walking within
the will of God no one and nothing can
do anything to you
because you are in Christ and he guards
you Proverbs 28 verse 26 says whoever
trusts in his own mind is a fool but He
Who Walks In wisdom will be delivered
you cannot trust the things of this
world that always let you down you
cannot trust in yourself because you're
not perfect and you always make mistakes
and you cannot trust in other people
because they always let you down
you can only trust in God
Psalm 20 verse 7 says some trust in
chariots and some in horses but we trust
in the name of the Lord our God
and Proverbs 3 verse 5 says trust in the
Lord with all your heart and do not lean
on your own understanding in all your
ways acknowledge Him and He will make
straight your paths and Psalm 118 Verse
8 says it is better to take refuge in
the Lord than to trust in man
you see placing your trust in God
relying on him instead of just relying
on your own
human abilities
man it changes everything because then
you don't even care about other people's
opinions you only care about what God
thinks of you and if you're walking
within his will because if you do
everything will work out the way it
should not only will it help you to
fight your battles but he will also give
you peace while you fight the battles
and those battles will come that is why
he has given you the Armor of God that
you need to put on every day and if you
do you will always have peace and joy
Isaiah 26 3 you keep him in perfect
peace whose mind is stayed on you
because he trusts in you
now start to live in God confidence and
not in self-confidence draw your
strength from the truth and Promises of
his word
and live it to live and overcome life's
challenges with Faith joy and unshakable
Trust in his divine plan
now if you want to grow stronger in God
then please watch one of these videos
here if you haven't subscribed do so now
so you won't miss any of our future
videos and I'll see you there and always
remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys